what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are we're really at the end
of superior spider-man I mean this is
the last story goblin nation but one of
the one of the reasons is something
about hoping you notice over the course
of the story one of the reasons why I
wanted to do the superior spider-man run
is because what dance law did with this
was either include kind of rap in or
offer some retcons with regards to the
creation of alchemax the company that
exists that's the main enemy of McGill
O'Hara and spider-man 2099 and so
assuming that we go forward and start
doing spider-man 2099 stuff what I
wanted this series to do is serve as
somewhat of like an origin story for
alchemax so that we could just kind of
jump into spider-man 2099 and I have to
go bootstrap explanations or so on and
so forth we could focus on the story
itself with you guys being able to
reference this material with regards to
where Miguel O'Hara is coming from and
how alchemax came into existence and
that's really what a lot of this does
this was really dad slot kind of showing
us the building of alchemax in real time
now we'll get to what alchemax is here
in a little bit for those people who are
new to the spider-man landscape because
again this is really all just kind of
giving people an idea of what spider-man
is about especially with the release of
the upcoming film as well as just kind
of passers-by who stumble across my
channel and have an interest in
spider-man but this basically coincides
with the Green Goblin Norman Osborn
making his move on New York and so
essentially what's been happening here
is he's been staging a series of
small-time skirmishes absorbing
different aspects of the criminal
underworld and this really comes out of
several different stories some of which
we need to know and have done and some
of which we don't really need to know
and we can kind of gloss over with
regards to the stuff that we do need to
know it's pretty much everything we've
covered in superior spider-man so far
that Norman Osborn was basically working
behind the scenes to make his triumphant
return to conquer New York on that carly
cooper the former girlfriend of peter
parker
had discovered the Doctor Octopus had
swapped minds with Peter Parker and she
kept it all recorded in a journal but
when she was kidnapped by the Green
Goblin you know what she was turned into
a goblin using the formula she basically
handed the journal over to Norman who in
turn read it and discover the fact that
Peter Parker and Doctor Octopus had
switched bodies the other half of this
is that in his attempts to basically
streamline the role of being spider-man
the superior spider-man had essentially
distributed all these different little
spider robots around the city of New
York and on the
they worked it would allow him to see
everything that was going on and so if
there was a crime taking place like a
mugging or something like that he didn't
need to intervene all he had to do was
just call the cops and the cops would
respond it allowed him to be virtually
everywhere at once but if it was a
massive event if it was some great big
huge calamity that required his
attention he could leave whatever was
that he was doing and go to that
particular incident the downside to this
is that Norman Osborn effectively
grabbed one of his BOTS managed to hack
into it using kind of a subroutine and
then in turn reprogram the robots so
they would never recognize anybody with
a goblin face and so they would
basically treat them as though they
didn't exist and what it did is it
allowed Noah Osborn to execute the
second part of his plan and the second
part of his plan was to basically build
a goblin army now this was composed of
several different things the first of
which was really the role of a guy named
Roderick Kingsley Roderick Kingsley as
we talked about before was the original
Hobgoblin he was designed to be the new
goblin that Spiderman would go against
following the death of the Green Goblin
now of course that's how he was written
but the Green Goblin was just so wildly
popular Marvel had to bring him back and
so the result was that we kind of got
Hobgoblin and Green Goblin and they both
serve different roles but they were both
relatively popular in the realm of in
the realm of Marvel comics but Roderick
Kingsley having long since more or less
abandoned the role of the Hobgoblin
essentially sort of taking all these
different identities and belonging to
small-time villains and then franchising
them out giving them the different
criminals allowing criminals to operate
as those you know under those bad guys
identities commit crimes so that nobody
would know that it was actually those
criminals so for example you know Phil
uric Phil Urich was operating as the
Hobgoblin for most of this story but
because of the fact that the identity of
the Hobgoblin is associated with
Roderick Kingsley Kingsley could remain
in hiding Phil Urich could be the
Hobgoblin and anybody who knew about
about the Hobgoblin would think that it
was Roderick Kingsley and not Phil Urich
and so again that's really how a lot of
these identities these you know these
villainous roles works themselves out at
the same time we also had the hand and
that came out of a story called a shadow
land but essentially all that really
dealt with was the idea that the hand
was being used by kingpin to basically
keep his thumb on the city of New York
the issue is that when superior
spider-man had basically invaded the
kingpins base of operations ran him out
of New York what was left of the hand
treated to Norman Osborn and joined his
goblin army and so that's really how a
lot of these things worked out it was
real just grabbing all these different
plot threads and just kind of bringing
them into one cohesive story and so the
result here is that we basically pick up
with Hobgoblin making his move now this
coincides with the idea that superior
spider-man is trying to figure out how
in the world it was that Hobgoblin
managed to circumvent his programming if
Hobgoblin I'm sorry I thought Green
Goblin is back if Norman Osborn is there
in the city of New York and superior
spider-man spider BOTS did not pick up
on his face then the question is why and
so this is what he basically goes any
visits a young kid by the name of who
watch you Jackson now watch you Jackson
was a member of horizon laughs and he
was actually the person who had designed
the facial recognition software of the
spider bots who would in turn catalog
criminals and Okafor superior spider-man
to use their identities later on if they
ever were to commit crimes he would know
who they were again part of the whole
streamlined process now of course the
law is not a bad guy here I mean he's
not a villain what we end up finding out
is that he had basically used a database
with regards to information that was
being sent out and so on and so forth
tapping into existing databases what the
Green Goblin did was basically hijack
this frequency and then reprogrammed the
facial software so the facial software
would never see goblins it would never
identify them and it would never
basically report back that a goblin had
been spotted and so again this creates
kind of a weird situation because what
this does is it basically leads to
superior spider-man using an underground
tunnel system that was formed by the
Green Goblin himself to allow his guys
to move back and forth throughout the
city without being detected - eventually
locate their base of operations now once
he gets there this person's a really
funny situation because we've never
really seen an instance this kind of
scenario before this has never taken
place and so what happens when the
number one villain of spider-man meets
the number two villain of spider-man
will they team up will they become
enemies Dan Slott gives us this really
cool scenario and what he basically says
is they're going to be enemies because
keep in mind while Doctor Octopus became
spider-man you know while he took over
the body of Peter Parker and his goal
was to become a bad guy in the moments
when their bodies are basically being
swapped and Peter realized there was no
way to regain his body back he basically
besieged Doctor Octopus dr. octopus
experience all the memories of Peter and
Peter said look there are people here
that I care about
my Aunt May I have a love for them
different things like that you have to
keep them safe you cannot let them be
harmed and it's really touched dr.
octopus in the heart of who he was and
so what it ended up doing is it
basically sent him on the path of being
a good guy leaving him up to this point
and so we're Green Goblin only sees dr.
octopus and recognizes him as one of
spider-man's most notable villains in
truth Doc Ock is a good guy now and so
with the two of them kind of going
against each other it really kind of
creates a funny scenario because what we
end up finding out here is that superior
spider-man is not actually here instead
it's more of a hologram but at the same
time Norman Osborn knows how to play
this game Norman Osborn is extremely
smart and what happened is that in the
midst of this meeting Osborn was tracing
the signal of superior spider-man back
to his base of operations on Spider
Island so again it's kind of cool
because it's basically both of them have
their own methods their own levels of
intelligence now what this does is this
brings into fruition the idea of the
Goblin formula now the Goblin formula in
and of itself is really one of multiple
instances when Marvel kind of hit home
with the idea that everybody was trying
to duplicate the Super Soldier Serum of
Steve Rogers and in fact we'll cover
this we'll talk about this once we get
into Ironman extremists because
futurepharm was trying to copy the Super
Soldier Serum and come up with extremis
instead but the doctor mains here that
the Goblin formula was designed to
basically enhance the various attributes
of the person who uses it the problem is
that it also breaks their sanity so they
literally lose their minds or at least
Norman Osborn ended up losing his mind
now for the most part different people
have been affected with it different
ways you know for example there was a
girl by the name of Lily Hollister who
was actually dating Norman Osborn for a
little while and stumbled across the
Goblin formula the difference is that
when she ingested it or when it
basically bonded to her skin that she
can switch out of being a goblin at will
you know she's not bound to losing her
sanity she doesn't lose her mind she can
just kind of switch back and forth how
she wants to so different people have
been affected different ways now if
enough time passes they'll just be gone
in their entirety I mean who they were
before will vanish and they'll just be
left as a goblin but for the moment for
her character things function a little
bit differently now from here we
basically switch back to the mindscape
of Peter Parker now again this is
something that we've talked about you
know time and time again just because of
the fact that would in the realm of
superior spider-man Doctor Octopus had
realized that the mind of Peter
Parker was still there because of the
fact that Peter Parker's consciousness
was tied directly to his memories and so
where doc Ock's had basically purged the
memories of Peter Parker
ideally it approached Peter Parker in
his entirety the issue with this is that
when Doc Ock had basically recalled on
memories of Peter in order to help him
navigate Peters life that is to say the
memories of Peters romance with Mary
Jane Watson or when Aunt May asked
something that Doctor Octopus didn't
know the answer to and he researched the
memories of Peter Parker in order to
give her an answer what it did is it
basically made these memories a core
part of Doctor Octopus and so Peter
Parker's consciousness remained alive
there's only about 30 memories that are
there but so long as any facet of Peters
memories are alive his life forces
essence are tied to those and so because
of the fact that octopus referenced
those memories at Peter Parker's
essentially alive through him the issue
is that Doc Ock could still purge Peter
in his entirety and so what happened is
Peter basically began jumping through
doctor octopus's own memories and what
this was is it was Dan Slott essentially
giving us a scenario where each guy
learns about the other dr. octopus
learns about the life of Peter Parker by
being Peter Parker Peter Parker
learns about the life of dr. octopus by
jumping into his own memories and what
he sees is a mother who is extremely
aggressive in terms of showing affection
which is to say she keeps him smothered
so on and so forth he has a father who's
extremely abusive he's picked on by kids
at school because he's socially awkward
you know all this time time and time
again Doc Ock has been met with nothing
but absolute oppression and just being
given a hard time by everybody and so
that guy grew up with a really bad life
and what this did is it allowed Peter
Parker to understand why Doc Ock is a
bad guy to understand where he's coming
from and why he's done the things that
he's done it's just been in pursuit of
some measure of acceptability or at the
very least trying to control his own
life and so with Norman Osborn making
his move across the city of New York the
response of Mayor Jay jonah Jameson is
to basically reactivate the DES
spider-slayer protocol that was created
by Alastair Smythe but in turn modified
this protocol so that the various
members of the you know anti spider
force as it was formed by Jameson would
be retrofitted with these new suits and
be allowed to carry out their goal of
basically clearing out New York of the
goblins themselves and essentially
restoring order now the reason why I say
this is basically the formation of
alchemax
the factory member lizallen had
basically taken out Allen chemical you
know al Kim and then merged it with
Oscorp for the purpose of creating
alchemax now of course we know about the
time displace spider-man 2099 that was
covered in the last video oh really the
video before the last video but what
this is doing is basically saying this
is how alchemax comes into existence
this is how alchemax forms it's
basically a merger between Oscorp and
Allen Chemical now in terms of what role
Norman Osborn has in this will actually
find out as we get further into this
story but the fact remains here that
with regards to to Peter Parker himself
with regards to superior spider-man
acting as Peter Parker what this does is
it really just kind of begins to show us
this struggle that he saw in relation or
at least Peter saw in relation to Doc
Ock in the sense that when Doc Ock first
became Doctor Octopus when he underwent
the experiment that basically bonded the
tentacles do his body he in turn saw
himself as somebody who could finally
get some respect some guy who could
finally be treated you know as the
genius that he knew he was now of course
this is going to lead into the crushing
experience of facing off against Peter
Parker and that's when things are really
going to kind of be kind of go awry but
it's also going to be the reason why doc
Octopus hated Peter Parker so much
because he was essentially the one guy
that just showed up and stood in his way
and here's a representation of a lot of
the other issues that he had but again
we'll cross that bridge when we get to
it the fact remains here that with
regards to really Carly Cooper you know
as one of the goblins invading Parker
Industries and going after so Johnny
Jeffery and you know superior spider-man
himself what we end up finding out is
that where Carly Cooper was previously
taken and turned into a goblin she's not
completely transformed yet instead
there's still some measure of her there
so while her physical body's changed her
mind is somewhat intact but this is what
we were talking about we were saying
that eventually a time will come when
who a person was will vanish in their
entirety and that's exactly what takes
place here with her as a person she
still has her mind intact and she tells
neo superior spider-man you have to make
a cure for this otherwise I will be gone
and Norman Osborn Green Goblin will
spread this formula across the city of
New York and everybody will be gone and
so again you know creates kind of this
this ticking time clock so to speak now
with regards to this formula while he is
working on it while superior spider-man
is putting it together ultimately he has
to bail out and the reason why is
because of the fact that Green Goblin
has essentially after learning that
superior spider-man is dr. octo
was waged a one-man war against him and
so this is really going to kind of serve
as a distraction and the reason why is
because of the fact that we're basically
going to have two conflicts going on in
this story at the same time we're going
to have Green Goblin versus superior
spider-man and then we're going to have
everybody else the Avengers and so on
going against the forces of the Green
Goblin so it's kind of like a two-stage
conflict now this is Green Goblin
playing two different games and the
reason why is because of the fact that
while he is crazy while he is out of his
mind
it's going to basically make it
difficult for superior spider-man to
actually create a cure for the Goblin
formula it's going to make it difficult
for him to save the ones that he cares
about because he's torn either it's the
city of New York or is the individuals
in his life and if you have to make a
choice between which one which person
will he choose now of course in this
instance you know we also have a couple
people who are more or less lost you
know people who basically end up dying
in the conflict but the interesting
thing about this is that again superior
spider-man had established himself as a
guy who wasn't really concerned about
casualties unless they were wildly
significant unless they were important
then it was just collateral damage
lesser price you pay when it comes to
wards some folks live in some folks side
and that's just the way it goes
now that was basically Dan Slott
differentiating him from Peter Parker
and in fact we'll find out just how
different these two are and what the
major failing is of superior spider-man
at this point but from here we again
have these spider-slayers as are
controlled by Jameson and the police and
so on engaging superior spider-man would
be intention of taking them out now the
reason why is because of the fact that
they look at superior spider-man and
they believe that he's in league with
the Green Goblin and the reason why is
because what they do is they look at his
track record keep in mind he's defeated
every major criminal in the city of New
York the only person left is the Green
Goblin - the person on the outside
looking in it would almost look like
superior spider-man was clearing out the
competition to make way for the Green
Goblin he was basically working on
behalf of Goblin to make the city easier
to conquer that's the initial indication
that's been received by Jameson and the
police and so on and so forth and so
where Miguel O'Hara does jump in and
Miguel O'Hara tries to basically help
you know and again really kind of allow
superior spider-man to stay captured for
the purpose of gaining answers
ultimately these robots are hijacked by
Norman Osborn and so again what does
shows us is that whether we knew it or
not
Osborn is tied
into alchemax he is involved in the
creation of these robots and does have a
back door and had to access them and so
again switching back to the mindscape of
a Peter Parker if this entire scenario
is really really intriguing because when
it shows as Peter directly what it gives
us or all these different conflicts with
Doctor Octopus and of course what we end
up finding out is that in the mind of
Doc Ock every time he was defeated by
Peter Parker it was yet another instance
of his father saying you're never going
to be anything it was another academic
professor saying you're dumb it's
another instance of kids who are
basically saying get out of here you're
not one of us
you're weird it was all the different
defeats that Doc Ock had faced over the
course of his life manifested in the
form of a singular guy named spider-man
and so because of that the hatred that
he had for spider-man just stretched the
absolute limits because it was like
spider-man represented every instance in
which Doc Ock had met some kind of a
road block over the course of his life
and so with that in mind we essentially
have Peter Parker trying to find a way
back to his own body at the same time
that all this is happening again one of
the things that Dan Slott does I really
enjoyed its basically bringing in the
Avengers because on the surface with a
story like this where the whole of New
York is being attacked a lot of writers
would not include ancillary teams I mean
bindus has done that on the multitude of
occasions they don't show the Avengers
they don't show anybody like that or any
other superheroes it's just this one guy
and we're somehow expected to believe
that the entire city of New York is
being attacked and this one hero is the
only one who knows about it were the
only one who cares enough to do anything
about it and so the cool thing about
this is like Captain America Iron Man
Thor Black Widow will reign Spider Woman
the New Avengers they're all responding
they're all you know doing what they can
to help keep New York safe now the
waiter depicted is within the charter of
the Avengers themselves The Avengers are
a peacekeeping force no fight if they
have to but with the city of New York
right now the one behind all this is the
Green Goblin and so their job is to take
down whatever enemies are there
specifically the forces of the Green
Goblin
and these different nearly seven Spider
Slayer robots would have been co-opted
and at the same time try to save as many
people as they can so again it's not
wildly important it's just kind of cool
to see this a little bit of a story
broad end this little bit of the events
included in this conflict but the fact
remains here that with Peter Parker
navigating this mindscape and basically
jump me back through the memories of
Doctor Octopus
really kind of retro actively retracing
his steps what he basically does is he
accesses the mind of Doctor Octopus
accesses the mind of his younger self
and in turn gives birth to all these
memories again and so basically he's
able to tap into everything that makes
him who he was now the reason why this
matters is because of the fact that
meant that Menace of course one of the
henchmen of the Green Goblin and several
others have created these traps around
the city of New York one of them is a
young girl named Amy chin now of course
Amy chin is one of the kids that the
superior spider-man has helped along the
way recovering from an illness but the
idea is that she's basically being
strapped in a subway station and she's
going to be hit by subway train now this
is where the huge difference between
Peter Parker and superior spider-man
comes into play superior spider-man is
analyzing the scenario remember he's
trying to trace and trying to locate an
Tamar Coney and save her life that's his
girlfriend that's the woman that he's
romantically interested in along the way
there's this girl named Amy chin he
cannot do both he cannot save annamaria
Marconi and Amy chin or at least it
doesn't seem to be the case and so where
he's paralyzed with indecision Peter
Parker manifests suddenly and says you
have to jump you have to go and this is
when we basically did the return of
Peter Parker and the reason why is
because Peter says look you know your
brain your intelligence is a gift in a
lot of different ways the things that
you do you know the things you've been
able to pull off or at least how you
look at things of course again Peter
doesn't know a lot of what's been going
on but he says you know the things that
you've done here are good in terms of
how you function the problem is when you
have no time to think you act when you
have time to think then you take that
time but you can't be pause or you can't
be paralyzed by indecision because
you're trying to make the right choice
and so in the end you know Doctor
Octopus basically realizes that Peter
had been navigating his mind and so the
indication seems to be here that he let
him that he let him basically access his
own memories but the fact remains the
Doctor Octopus and Peter essentially
reconciled you know Doctor Octopus says
look the biggest issue that I had is
that sure you know I was arrogant but it
was because of the fact that I was
trying to overcompensate is because of
the fact that I knew I was not as smart
as you are but I wanted to pretend that
I was and so Peter Parker is really kind
of speechless throughout this whole
thing is because it's Doctor Octopus
spilling his guts out to Peter basically
saying you aren't a better
spider-man than I will ever be you know
because when it comes to self-sacrifice
you do it without a second
but I can't bring myself to do that and
so again it's really kind of this cool
thing because it's like this journey
really in some ways a journey of Peter
Parker in a sense that it's almost like
you know you don't know what you have
until it's gone
as it was like Dan Slott basically
saying okay let's take Peter Parker as
we know him out of the equation with
spider-man
let's put somebody else in his stead and
then let's see how these stories unfold
once we get to the end let's compare the
two and see how they stack up against
one another and so ultimately what Doc
Ock basically does is travel back to
Parker industries of course Peter Parker
being totally surprised by the fact that
there is a Parker Industries but they
travel back to the building and Peter
Parker regains his memories he goes back
to his normal self and what we get is
this amazing thing because we have Peter
Parker back to himself back in his own
body he gets rid of the superior
spider-man sued he puts on his amazing
spider-man suit and he says my turn and
it's so cool it's one of the coolest
things I was reading this and I was like
oh my god like Peter Parker's back
amazing spider-man is back and it's one
of the coolest things to happen because
as soon as Peter Parker regains control
of his own body remember he has no idea
what's been going on with like Parker
Industries what's been going on with
horizon labs he has no idea what's been
happening there instead all he knows is
that he's just back now so I mean you
know Carly Cooper being turned into a
goblin he didn't know about that
you know the launch of Parker industry
so Johnny joffrey and Anna Maria Marconi
working for the company he didn't know
about that so as soon as he shows up he
just starts getting screamed at by
people they're just like why have you
been gone all this time you know and and
carrying on because of the fact that you
know again superior spider-man had
basically taken off he had made Parker
Industries and then banished from a
company for like a month he had
abandoned Miguel O'Hara to face off
against all these different
spider-slayer robots and then when he
shows back up again Miguel O'Hara kind
of freaks out on him now again this is
really kind of cool because the two of
them of course end up teaming up and
Peter Parker jumps back in the conflict
alongside the rest of the Avengers and
really kind of making up for the things
that superior spider-man did where
superior spider-man with the Avengers
Peter Parker rejoins different things
like that now of course when we end up
getting into the direct conflict between
the Green Goblin along the way Peter
Parker had basically been doing things
like injecting menace
with a cure for the Goblin formula which
basically turns her back in Inaugural
turns her back to normal again they've
been doing this almost every step of the
way
ah but with the return with the conflict
between Peter and Norman Osborn's
basically on the rooftop alongside Anna
Maria Marconi Green Goblin learns that
Peter Parker's back because of the fact
the Green Goblin makes a joke about how
Green Goblin is going to destroy yeah
really makes a joke about how he's going
to destroy everything that spider-man
loves and spiral says you know what the
only thing that I'm left with is the
dignity of knowing that I never carried
a man-purse so despite the fact where
spider-man giving Green Goblin
about his satchel that's how we know is
that Peter Parker's back it's amazing I
absolutely love this part of the story
it's one of the coolest things but again
it's really kind of refreshing to see
Peter Parker back because which is
character what it does is it creates
urgency and it creates struggle and it
creates strife because Peter Parker
saves everyone right like no one dies
whenever it is and Peter Parker's around
if at all possible with the superior
spider-man the storytelling had to be a
little bit different because he'll kill
bad guys we've seen that it was just
like we're gonna kill him and then we're
going to be done with it and they won't
come back that's that but when Peter
Parker is in a scenario where he has to
save annamaria Marconi and he has to
defeat the Green Goblin while going
without letting Green Goblin die
basically saving his life then it makes
things difficult and it makes things
hard now in terms of the whole idea
without the max we end up having this
situation where we will basically learn
that Norman Osborn had had his face
changed that what he did is he took on
the name of a guy named Mason banks and
he began operating as a de facto
investor on behalf of Osborn born
industry so because of the I guess on an
Oscorp rather and so because of that
what he did is he turn around and
invested alongside Lidz Allen which in
turn allowed for the merger of Oscorp
and Al Corp to create alchemax and so
again this is really kind of a funny
scenario because what ends up happening
here is Peter Parker basically turns the
robots these little you know fries
little Goblin box against Mason Banks
himself which really just kind of leaves
him incapacitated slightly or enough
that he's lost his goblin you know it's
goblin abilities because of the
injection that Peter Parker gave him
basically curing him of the Goblin
formula but in saving annamaria Marconi
he also saves you know Norman Osborn
with a different face at the same time
and so again what this does is kind of
wrap things up because Norman Osborn
essentially escapes he basically just
kind of gets away and that's really that
kind of takes off into the tunnels and
Dan Slott leaves
open-ended you know for norman osborn to
come back later on down the line but we
all what we also end up having here is
this notion that Anna Maria Marconi
still doesn't know everything that's
going on she doesn't know that Doctor
Octopus was in the body of Peter Parker
as far as she is aware it's Peter Parker
who's in love with her and so what Dan
Slott does is he kind of leaves this
open and says there will be fallout
there will be consequences there will be
ramifications in the Amazing Spiderman
line of stories when things go back to
normal because what we basically got to
have is Peter Parker having to sit down
and explain to the various members of
the the people in his life who he is and
what exactly it was that was going on so
again it's really kind of a cool bit of
storytelling it's really a pretty
interesting tidbit of events that were
that were taking place but if you guys
are new here to comment to explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you guys on
earth peace
[Music]